tous mais qui voilà comment ça va
regarder
regardez de combat paraît aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on va parler d'image on va
par les télévisions on va parler de sony
boulanger m'a demandé de vous parler de
ce téléviseur de sony c'est la sony à 90
j c'est un tout nouveau modèle de 2021
alors cette télé elle est intéressante
dans plein d'univers différents donc on
va se regarder ensemble on va regarder
si elle est potentiellement fait pour
vous on va regarder ce qu'elle sait
faire ce qu'elle peut faire on va
regarder les particularités on va
regarder à qui il est destiné vous allez
voir cette télé les superbes et super
bien pour tout vous dire je vais être
très clair l'année dernière j'ai testé
une télé de sony ça fait donc quelques
longs mois déjà que je suis utilisateur
d'une télé de sony pas ce modèle là d'un
modèle de l'année dernière avait
d'ailleurs déjà présenté ce modèle là en
vidéo sur youtube
et quand boulanger est venu me dire
tiens on a une nouvelle télé de sony à
te faire tester je dis bien évidemment
je suis intéressé parce que je connais
la qualité de leurs dalles les dalles
bravia de sony qui marche super bien
l'idée de ne pas avoir de haut parleurs
mais d'avoir en de l'écran qui vibre
d'avoir une dalle qui libre qui vous
restitue du son en plus avec deux
caissons de basses diwan je trouvais ça
super intéressant je vais vous expliquer
ils n'ont pas dû technique ce qui à
l'intérieur
l'idée de l'expérience l'idée d'avoir
des bords extrêmement forts sur le côté
en plus ici à plusieurs configurations
sur la hauteur la gemmi la configuration
pour pouvoir mettre une barre de son
deux sous le truc qui est super
intéressant avec ça c'est que ça vous
dégagez vous avez la barre de son c'est
bien moi la problématique que j'ai ici
c'est que j'ai un petit meuble
vous pouvez aussi la pose et la flore du
meuble mais moi ça ne va pas aller du
tout avec mon meuble et ça ne
correspondra pas à mon l'intérieur alors
je vais tout vous montrer tout vous
expliquer tout vous détailler et vous à
lyon à la première chose à savoir cette
télé c'est l'image pour les amoureux de
films les amoureux de cinéma on a un
truc qui est vraiment bien qu'est ce
qu'elle nous raconte cette télé chez
elle nous raconte déjà question d'un
très grand écran ici si un format 55
pouces et une 139 de diamètre alors il
existe différents formats vous l'avez en
65 pouces vous l'avez également en 81 3
pouces mois 55 sandaga lors la première
chose à voir
d'un point de vue purement esthétique
c'est vraiment ici c'est tout faire je
vous chante pas la chanson c'est
vraiment too far gardella le borc vous
avez là il est plus petit monde ongles
c'est vraiment tout fait tout feu tout
femme donc ça c'est génial d'un point de
vue design d'avoir quelque chose
d'extrêmement
fin il perd bien intégré dans un
intérieur personnellement j'aime
beaucoup donc ça vraiment c'est pour moi
un très gros point positif alors l'autre
point qui est sympa c'est au niveau des
pieds alors ici moi ce que j'ai fait
c'est parce que le plus beau pourquoi
parce que vous voyez des bouts de câbles
qui pendouille ici et qui pendouille
juste là mais moi j'étais bloqué
pourquoi et bien tout simplement à cause
de la large en meubles si vous regardez
là je suis à l'extrémité
et si on vient regarder la la je suis
également l'extrémité est normalement
cette télé elle fonctionne pas
réellement comme ça elle est faite pour
être posée à fleurs comme ça soit vous
venez la poser à fleurs effectivement
dans votre écran il vient vraiment se
positionner sur le bas et vous voyez pas
tout ça voyez pas les passages de câbles
c'est la raison pour laquelle ils vous
ont pas intégrer deux passages de câbles
contrairement au modèle que j'avais d'un
meilleur ou au passage de câbles il se
faisait directement dans les pieds
c'était beaucoup mieux là ici ils ont
pris le parti de se dire ok ça va être
un poil plus large sauf que moi mon
meuble il vraiment optimisé pour 1 55
pouces à peut pas dépasser le problème
c'est que le pied dans notre
configuration il va arriver sur le côté
ici comme ça est pareil de l'autre côté
et chez moi c'est pas possible ce qui
fait que la télé elle tenait pas sur mon
meuble
j'ai donc dû le mettre en position comme
pour avoir une barre de son alors il
existe une troisième position où vous
allez pouvoir mettre les pieds au centre
là mais bon je trouvais pas ça non plus
très très pratiques ont préféré mettre
comme ça donc avec ou sans barre de son
ça ira très bien comme ça que ça dépend
où une fois de plus de la taille de
votre meuble il ya un truc qui est assez
sympa nous a fait son nid en arrière
nous ont mis plein de cash pour venir
planquer les connectiques bon alors
normalement vous êtes contre un mur face
au patro maison souci du détail ils ont
dit on va mettre des caches bon vous
montre d'ailleurs c'est pas mal déjà
commencé pas voilà alors regardez j'ai
déjà un cash qui est là qui vient pour
s'enlever voilà effectivement je maman
d'alimentation générale
j'ai un autre cache qui est planqué je
crois juste ici je vais retrouver mes
connectique troisième cache pareil je
tire et je retrouve ici mais connectique
sur le côté et là vous avez des
connecteurs pour venir brancher un ampli
qui vous permettra d'utiliser le système
son vote télécom enceinte centrale dans
un système de home cinéma
vous avez une entrée vidéo ou une prise
jack on a deux prises usb
on a deux hdmi ici et puis rester
planqué juste en dessous si vous avez
une sortie optique une prise ethernet de
quoi brancher un satellite et vous avez
encore ici du
vous avez 3 prises hdmi ici et dont
justement regardez là ça j'ai pas si
vous le voyez bien qu'il y ait marqué
quatre cas 120 hertz 4k sens alors
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent bien nous
proposait de la 4 car sans rire je pense
que je vous apprends rien sony s'est pas
uniquement de la télé sony c'est au
cinéma c'est aussi la musique et sony
c'est également le gaming avec les
consoles et notamment avec la
playstation 5 qui était sorti l année
dernière et on a donc ici une entrée 4
cash daily 120 hertz pour avoir le
maximum de fluidité pour les expériences
de gaming à la nage pour sa super
l'intégration c'est à dire que vous
venez brancher votre console ici qui va
supporter du 4k à 120 images par
secondes vous et pouvoir aller beaucoup
plus loin au niveau l'expérience de
gaming avec un taux de rafraîchissement
sans mayotte dès lors qu'il est supporté
par votre console guen évidemment et
c'est un peu l'idée on va donc ici avec
ce téléviseur sony cherche à draguer les
gamers on a donc une très bonne
expérience au niveau de la dalle pour du
visionnage notamment avec une dalle oled
4k uhd avec tout plein de technologies
que le trees parfaitement bien sonnés il
ya technologie exr contraste pour une
luminosité et des contrastes totalement
injuste et x r colour pour avoir des
couleurs complètement réaliste exr
clarity qui vous permet de faire un axe
kyling jusqu en 4k c'est à dire que si
vous avez un contenu full hd et bien il
va pouvoir venir monter en qualité pour
avoir une qualité quatre cas même si la
source n'est pas qu'à la technologie x
air motion clarity pour avoir une action
plus fluide plus lumineuse et plus clair
et en plus de ça vous avez un capteur
lumière rvb qui va venir optimiser les
couleurs par rapport à l'éclairage si
vous mettez des couleurs plus froides
des couleurs plus chaudes et bien vous
aurez toujours le même rendu sans votre
téléviseur grâce aux capteurs donc ça
c'est aussi sympa tout ça est rendu
possible grâce aux cognitif processor
ixair qui va venir analyser votre image
élément par élément pour venir booster
les contrastes les couleurs les détails
que la scène soit parfaite et ce quel
que soit l'image que vous allez lui
proposer l'idée de ce processeur
cognitif ces deux d'abord un traitement
aussi proche que possible du cerveau
humain qui va venir traiter élément par
élément bout d'image par bouts d'image
si vous avez un papillon va venir
traiter le papillon indépendamment de la
girafe à côté vous avez compris un peu
le truc c'est vrai que le rendu se sont
super super super qualitatif est ici
comment les sur une dalle oled on a des
noirs profonds puisqu'un pixels noirs
est un pixel est peint la restitution
des couleurs est vraiment bien maîtrisé
voilà l'image je la trouve super mais
après si vous souhaitez vous pouvez
aller dans vos paramètres pourraient
venir modifier l'image en fonction de ce
que vous voulez de ce que vous voulez
voir mais comme elle est là nativement
ça marche vraiment bien
alors moi il ya une techno qui m'avait
vachement surpris l'année dernière
j'avais jamais testé de téléviseurs de
sony auparavant je n'avais vu dans des
salons jean davy dans des magasins ne
les avez jamais essayé eh bien c'est ce
qui s'appelle l'acoustique surface donc
ici on est sûr de l'acoustique surface
audio plus alors je vous passe lui on la
techno je vous explique ce que c'est en
fait il faut savoir qu'ici vous n'avez
pas de haut parleurs pour vos médium
grave aigu non il n'ya pas de haut
parleurs c'est votre dalle qui va servir
de haut parleurs en fait ce qu'il va se
passer ici c'est que vote donne elle va
venir vibrer plusieurs fois par seconde
pour créer le son de la même manière je
le ferais haut parleurs sauf qu'ici il
n'ya pas de membres ait pas de haut
parleurs ça marche pas comme ça c'est
donc la vibration de vote dalle qui va
créer le son qui va créer l'audio ce qui
fait donc que votre son sort réellement
de vote d'aller non pas d'en haut
parleurs qui serait déportée ça rajoute
en immersion
on s'en rend pas compte a clairement que
c'est la dalle et quand on vous dit vous
n'avez pas d'eau par leur ces votes
dalle qui vibre grâce à cette
technologie
c'est vraiment bluffant pour bien
comprendre cette technologie se sont ce
qu'on appellera des actionnaires qui
vont faire vibrer votre talent vous avez
donc ici une puissance de 2 x 20 watts
pour vos deux actionnaires et d'iwate
parquet sont basses pour un total de 60
watts
en plus de ça ils sont blagueur chez
sony parce qu'ils vous ont rajouté
d'autres technologies pour venir
améliorer le son il ne suffisait pas
d'avoir une dalle qui vibrait d'abord
d'un caisson de basses sur le côté non
ils vont plus loin ils vous ont
notamment mis la technologie vol zoom de
alors qu'est ce que fait voler ou mme et
ben en fait c'est une analyse du spectre
pour repérer les voies et pour les
détacher les rendre plus clairs ce qui
fait que si vous êtes dans un
environnement où il ya du bruit autour
de vous et vous allez pas forcément
réussir à bien capté leçons des voix et
bien laissons d'en sortir plus clair le
reste un peu plus atténuée pour mieux
venir les distinguer vous avez également
une technologie son surround ixair qui
va venir répartir le son à 360 degrés
autour de votre téléviseur pour vous le
quartier avec plus d'immersion et puis
en plus on a l'expérience google tv
google tv c'est super intéressant alors
qu'est ce que google tv va venir vous
apporter ici google tv c'est le
successeur d' android tv est ce que vous
regrettez les affaires si vous apportez
une expérience qui va toujours plus loin
dans l'univers google à roxy tu es
d'accord avec moi ouais je suis super
d'accord avec toi c'est génial mon
concours vous allez pouvoir piloter
votre télé à la voix si vous avez une
enceinte un google
nestor brune est mini et bien vous
pouvez venir allumer éteindre votre télé
montrent elles sont par exemple ici ok
google est à la télé ok ok google allume
la télé c'est quand même mieux pour vous
en parler d'abord la télé allumée
donc je peux venir la piloter montel
sondé ses leçons je peux et demandé de
mettre netflix de m spotify est ce que
j'ai un gros catalogue d'applications
quand c'est vachement bien arrête de
manger les doigts roxy donc je peux
venir également depuis ma télé venir
piloter grâce à la voix maison connectée
allumer la lumière et à de la lumière en
fonction bien évidemment du fait que
vous ayez des lumières connecter chez
vous et toute votre écosystème tout
votre domotique pouvait venir la piloter
à la voix depuis votre télé et je peux
venir faire de la recherche main libre
de la même manière que je le ferai avec
n'importe quelle enceinte google je vais
avoir notamment des films des séries
espoir retrouvé sur netflix disney +
mick hannah les compagnies prennent
vidéo en fonction de mes abonnements
j'ai ma bibliothèque bon pas pour
l'instant vous avez vu lé ville je peut
rechercher des choses avec google
assistants et là j'ai mes applications
donc ma telle est ma télé en fait quand
je vais venir l'allumer ça va mal vu
mais ma box de bouygues telecom qui est
juste là comme ça je vais pouvoir
regarder mes contenus sur ma télé avec
notre box et ce qui est bien et je vous
en reparle dans quelques instants la
télécommande elle elle me permet de
piloter directement ma boxe que j'ai en
bas donc pas besoin de doter les
commandes j'en ai une seule message
giuly dans quelques instants et si je
vais dans un parti qui s'appelle
application juste en haut
eh bien je vois que jax et à toutes mes
applis je peux venir rechercher des
applis et ensuite j'ai différentes
thématiques style de vie sport actualité
magazine productivité enseignements
enfin il y en a plein je vois que j'ai
et spotify que je peux aussi installés
pour venir écouter ma musique c'est joël
soit directement ici alors moi j'ai les
enceintes connectés je préférerais
plutôt que la télé mais si je veux je
peux le faire dailymotion et compagnie
n'ont envoyé il ya plein d'applis il ya
un très très gros catalogues et même
facebook watch si vous le souhaitez donc
on comprend ici que dans cet univers-là
avec cette google télé on peut installer
très facilement des tonnes
d'applications y en a plein il y en a
tous les côtés on peut venir jouer à des
jeux on peut venir écouter de la musique
on peut venir regarder des films bien
évidemment sous réserve d'avoir souscrit
aux abonnements et tout ça sur une télé
avec un son qui marche très bien une
superbe qualité d'image
voilà que yards mais alors il ya un bel
effort qui était fait également sur la
télécommande et je trouve plus sympa que
celle qu'on avait l'année dernière fois
que celle que moi je vois une arnaque
étaient toutes en plastique là on a un
côté vraiment métal brossé ya un aspect
beaucoup plus premium
on va retrouver tout ce dont on a besoin
ce route et les commandes tout
numéro ici surtout ça c'est vachement
intéressant vous avez ici vos
différentes applications youtube netflix
disney plus près une vidéo alors qu'à
une époque on a des rakuten tv netflix
sur beaucoup de télécommande
là on voit qu'on a un raccourci pour
toutes ces applications là qui sont
installés directement nativement donc ça
commence à vraiment très très très malin
après ce qu'on va utiliser ici c'est le
bouton pour la commande vocale pour
venir lui parler bon petit pavé on s'en
doutera mettre votre télé bas comme un
grand classique changer les chaînes
montel son baisser le son à prévenir à
lancer un enregistrement play pause
donc on a vraiment une télécommande que
je trouve assez premium très sympa un
peu grandin et franchement mais surtout
ce qui est intéressant avec celle là est
bien c'est que vous n'avez pas besoin
d'autres télécommande c'est une smart
remote elle est intelligente et la
pouvoir venir notamment commander ici
votre blog parce que oui si elle va
venir commander ma boxe autre point qui
est super sympa avec ce téléviseur c'est
qu'on est compatible ici apple airplay
ix2 chrome caste apple homme quitte mais
également amazon avec ça elle est
également compatible avec les formats
dolby vision imax enhanced adnane stade
j'ai jamais réussi à prononcer ce mot
navire et c'est un peu compliqué elle
est compatible en tout cas vous l'avez
compris l alleud netflix calibre eight
mode
l'idée c'est que netflix prend en main
les paramétrages vidéo pour que l'image
que vous ayez sur votre téléviseur soit
vraiment l'image que le réalisateur a
voulu avoir
on a donc les amoureux de cinéma et
séries qui sont ciblés mais également
tous les amoureux de gaming et je vous
dis notamment grâce à cette prise hdmi 4
k 120 hertz en hdmi 2.1
il ya un input lac est vraiment réduit
une latence qui est inférieur à 8 5
millisecondes
vous savez le mode de jeu qui est
développé en partenariat avec
playstation voilà sony travaille avec
sony sont ces malades su et vous pouvez
venir tous connectés dans votre
intérieur votre maison communiquer avec
google avec apple
chrome castet compagne donc voyons une
télé qui est vraiment complète pour
toute la famille qui est très large que
vous soyez guy que vous soyez gamer que
vous soyez amoureux de films et de
séries vous avez une proposition qui est
super bien et au tarif de et au tarif de
tout est écrit ici au tarif de 2690
europe au moment auquel je fais cette
vidéo aujourd'hui directement chez
boulanger je vous ai mis une fois de
plus le lien en bas dans la description
pour conclure on a pour moi trois points
essentiels sur cette télé
d'abord c'est une parfaite harmonie
entre le son et l'image via le réalisme
avec bravia exr plus un son de qualité
qui suit l'action directement sur votre
téléviseur
il ya les sensations cinéma à la maison
avec bravia corps plus toutes les
technos
audio et vidéo qui sont associés et puis
surtout ça va être un excellent
compagnon provost pour le gaming avec
votre ps -cinq au travers notamment de
la connectique et d'un mot de jeux
optimisés donc vous l'aurez compris moi
je suis conquis par ce téléviseur sony
continue à menacer dans cette qualité
sony à un tarif un petit peu supérieur à
2500 euros
ça reste un budget mais vu la qualité de
ce qu'on a aussi vu la qualité de la
dalle vu la qualité audio vu
l'expérience vu la connectivité vu la
compatibilité vu l'univers de films de
gaming et compagnie je trouve ça bien et
même roxy elle adorait ou même roxy et
adore oui moi aussi j'adore je me rends
commandes voilà j'arrête de faire de
ventriloque avec les chiens en tout cas
j'aime bien voilà donc si elle vous
intéresse bien évidemment je vous ai mis
les liens en bas dans la description on
continuera par les téléviseurs parce
qu'à plein de choses à raconter et bien
évidemment c'est un élément central de
la maison connectée donc donc on en
reparlera sur ce prenez soin de vous à
très bientôt j'embrasse les gros bisous
et bien et puis à bientôt pas bientôt
quitter du regard occidental